[Musik]
das schicke die verfilmung von journey
kontakt des romans von dave eggers der
vor einigen jahren ich bin 2014
herauskam und möglich für ungeheures
aufsehen sorgte
nicht weil es ein besonders gutes buch
gewesen wäre das kann man wirklich sagen
sondern weil es eine welt beschrieben
hat von der damals noch nicht alle
glaubten und nicht alle wussten da ist
es möglicherweise und zwar mit
ziemlicher sicherheit mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit unsere zukunft sein
wird vorerst zu yoga war es ein schock
für jedes mal einkaufen ein anderes auto
benötigt wurde
und so viele autos braucht kein mensch
dass wir einfach quatsch das chaos im
netz wird dadurch elegante es ging um
eine firma in kalifornien sie steht für
drei darf man vermuten die an der
vollständig transparenten welt arbeitet
man hat bei dieser firma ein konto ein
passwort und alle daten werden dort
gesammelt verwaltet und überwacht
am ende des ganzen steht der
transparente mensch der vollständig
transparente mensch der nicht nur
ausspioniert wird sondern ganz
freiwillig sich und sein leben der welt
zur ansicht preisgibt
der film wiederholt eigentlich das was
an dem buch nicht gut nämlich einen
wirklich ärmlichen realismus dass dieser
ärmliche realismus zeichnet die sprache
von dave eggers in dem buch aus und
mache das ganze blatt und flach ab heute
trage ich zu jeder zeit eine
modifizierte change kamera und das ohne
außen der film hat auch diesen dumpfen
realismus der ohne dynamik ohne
wirkliche bilder an die man sich
erinnern könnte auskommen muss aber das
erstaunlich ist eben wenn tom hanks
auftritt der ja ein guru spielt und
einen kleinen einen mann der für diese
grauenhaften ideen das transparent diese
grauenhafte idee des transparenten
menschen irgendwie johlen mit zustimmung
erreichen kann wenn er die bühne betritt
und damit den film betritt sieht man
sofort das ist ein star
und man merkt wenn die mittel etwas
filmischer gewählt worden wären dass der
filmstadt die schwächen des buches zu
verstärken die schwächen des buches auch
hätte unterspülen können und wir
vielleicht wirklich echt eine vision
eine alptraum vision eine starke eine
intensive geschichte hätten sehen können
auf der leinwand
das passiert aber leider nicht ja
richtig gehört
er ist die gäste beim server die ihr
gesamtes berufs und privatleben mit der
öffentlichkeit teilen wird dafür ein und
extra applaus bei uns figur dieser neuen
idee vollständiger transparenz wird
gespielt von emma watson
sie heißt ist fast in jeder einstellung
eigentlich zu sehen
und ich muss sagen ich hätte mir eine
kraftvollere darstellung gewünscht
das ist alles sehr brav in gewisser
weise und grau und unentschieden also
ich habe nicht gehen das ist nicht eine
figur über die ich weiter nach denke es
ist auch nicht die figur über die ich
mir große sorgen mache es ist trotzdem
es ist völlig spannungslos und auch die
emma watson ist in ihrem spiel völlig
ohne ohne dynamik letztlich das ist
einer der großen hindernis in diesem
film mit dass man sich engagiert für
irgendetwas eine der beiden seiten
dass der ton immer auf eine ist immer so
auf einer ebene erhebt sich nicht läuft
aber auch nicht ab sondern ist in so
einer unentschlossenen mittellage die
das ganze unendlich langweilig macht
muss ich leider sagen willst du wissen
ist gut
haben wir alles zu wissen
ist besser
[Applaus]